[संगीत]
[प्रशंसा]
ए
[संगीत]
हेलो एवरीवन गुड इवनिंग दोस्तों एक बार आप
लोग यह बता दीजिए सबको मेरी आवाज सुने दे
रही है
चाट में फटाफट बता दीजिए
यस या नो बता दीजिए एक बार
[संगीत]
हेलो थैंक यू
2000 क्या करने वाले देखो चलो
तो सबसे पहले आप सभी का स्वागत हमारे
डिप्लोनिक्स अकादमी के युटुब चैनल पर तो
आज का हमारा टॉपिक क्या है अगेन जो लास्ट
क्लास हमने कहां पर छोड़ था की इमेज ओपन
सोशल इंटेलिजेंस वहां चला रहा था उसकी
लास्ट क्लास है क्योंकि थर्ड क्लास इसलिए
है क्योंकि अब टोटली प्रैक्टिकल क्लास है
कुछ एक लैब है टोटल पुरी की पुरी लाइफ हम
आपके सामने लाइव सॉल्व करेंगे तो आप लोग
देखिए कैसे सॉल्व होता है अगर हो सके तो
आप भी कर सकते हो कोई सुन नहीं है अगर
आपके पास लैपटॉप है तो अगर मैं साथ साथ
में अगर बीच में कहानी थोड़ा बोलते ब्रेक
ले रहा हूं तो प्लीज सॉरी पर डेट आई एम
टेकिंग मी टी इवनिंग टी थॉट्स वही तो
चलो फिर हम चलते हैं हम चलते हैं
तो ये कैसा प्लेटफॉर्म है जहां पर आप सारे
के सारे जितने भी बंटी है या कुछ भी है
जितने भी फैन टेस्टिंग है कुछ भी है यहां
से सिख सकते हो यहां पर क्या है
प्रैक्टिस कर सकते हो ईटीएफ खेल सकते हो
इसकी बेस पे की आपको अच्छी प्रैक्टिस में
हो जाएगी और यहां से क्या की आपको रियल
लाइफ मजा आएगा की कैसे बुक्स मिलते हैं
कैसे
उनके बड़े में
आप कैसे कौन सा मतलब इससे आपको ये हेल्प
मिलेगी की आपकी खुद की मेट्रोलॉजी उसे
करके की आप कैसे उसको फाइंड आउट कर का रहे
हो
एक बार मैं इसको जॉइन कर लेट हूं फटाफट
इसके बाद हम इस लैब को सॉल्व करने वाले
कंपलीटली
ओके वेलकम तू सब्सक्राइब अमन रूम ओके इन
दिस रूम यू बिल बी एक्सप्लोरिंग थे
डिसिप्लिन का इमेज ओपन सो सिंटोली
इंटेलिजेंस और जिओ इंटेलिजेंस विच इसे डी
शॉर्ट पर इमेज इंटेलिजेंस और योर
स्पिरिचुअल इंटेलिजेंस दिस रूम इस सिटेड
पर डोज ऑफ यू हूं आर जस्ट बिगनिंग योर ओपन
सोर्स इंटेलिजेंस जर्नी और डोज ब्रांड
न्यू तू डी फील्ड ऑफ इमेज इन आईटी पर जिओ
इन आईटी ओके तो इसमें कुछ लिखा हुआ है कुछ
साड़ी चीज हैं उसमें हम ध्यान नहीं देंगे
अगर आप चाहे तो आप लोग सब कुछ आप लोगों को
ध्यान देने की जरूर है पर मुझे ऐसा पढ़ने
की जरूर नहीं है डायरेक्टली कम करने वाले
हैं तो इसमें क्या है ये बोल रहा है की
अगर आपको कोई फ्लैग सबमिट करवाना होगा
मेरे क्वेश्चंस का कोई भी आंसर आप सॉल्व
करोगे तो आपको क्या है यह पैटर्न आपको आगे
लिखना है और उसके बाद आपको क्या करना अपना
आंसर सबमिट करना है
सबमिटेड
नो रिक्वायर्ड ओके तो आपको क्या आंसर भी
क्या करना है रेडी कर देना तो एक बार मैं
हां आई एम रेडी
उसके बाद मैं इनको बता देता हूं
चलो हम सबसे पहले फर्स्ट चैलेंज क्या है
तो फर्स्ट चैलेंज किया है की हम एक कम
करते हैं इसको डाउनलोड कर लेते हैं के बाद
यह जो भी मैंने टेक्निक्स आपको सिखाई है
वह साड़ी यहां पर अप्लाई होने वाली है मैं
इसको क्या करता हूं डाउनलोड करता हूं
टास्क 2 हमने डाउनलोड के लिए इसको हम ओपन
करते हैं अब एक इमेज है आपके सामने दिखाई
दे रही होगी मैं आपको दिखता हूं और ये रही
ये वो इमेज को जूम करता हूं इन्होंने कुछ
एक ऐसे इमेज ऐसे इमेज प्रोवाइड की है
तो इस इमेज में कुछ देखते हैं की सबसे
पहले इमेज को देखकर आप सबको पता है की जब
भी आपके पास कोई इमेज आई है तो उसके पास
आपको लिए आपको क्या करना है उसपे इमेज
एनालिसिस करने के लिए आपको पांच टेक्निक
बोला था मैंने एक तो कांटेक्ट बैकग्राउंड
पर ग्राउंड
के आगे कुछ चीज हैं इसके बड़े में क्या
करते हैं तो एनालिसिस करते हैं फर्स्ट
इमेज है की आप हमें क्या देखने जूम करता
हूं आपको देखने को मिल रहा है वेलकम तू
कैन
बाय वेलकम तू करना बाय स्टेट और आपको यहां
क्या देखने को मिल रहा है
आपको क्या देखना है 22 स्टॉल विच स्टोर
एफ ओ आर एन ओ आर एन ओ ऐसा कुछ लिखा हुआ है
बट क्या है की बहुत ही सिंपल चैलेंज रहेगा
ये तो सबसे पहले हम देखते हैं की वह क्या
पूछना चाहता है हमसे क्वेश्चन क्वेश्चन का
आंसर क्या देना है यह बोल रहा है आपको
क्या करना है वो स्टेप ये व्हाट इसे डी
नाम ऑफ डी स्टेट वेयर दिस इमेज आपको क्या
करना है की उसे जगह का नाम बताना उसे प्ले
का नाम बताना जहां पे फोटो ली गई है तो
हमारे पास वैसे तो एक छोटी सी फोटो है बट
क्या-क्या इसमें देखें तो वेलकम तू ए करना
बेस्ट लिखा हुआ है इसके ऊपर तो वैसे तो
देखने को तो यही मुझे लगता है इसका आंसर
हो जाना चाहिए अदर वाइस अगर ये इसका आंसर
नहीं तो हम क्या करेंगे इसको एक बार इमेज
रिवर्स करके भी देख लेंगे आपको पता चल
जाएगा तो इसका कोई कम करता हूं मैं
इमेज रिवर्स सर्च करके हम परफॉर्म करते
हैं तो ये रहा ये ए जाइए और अपलोड कर
देंगे
आपको देखने को मिल रहा होगा और इसके बीच
में मैसेज भी ए गई युटुब पे भी है ये काफी
जगह मैंने इसके बड़े में ओनली उसने नाम
पूछा था हमसे तो क्या करते हैं
क्या यही हमारा आंसर होगा
सभी कम सॉल्व करने की कोशिश करेंगे टोटली
तो इसलिए क्या की हम एक एक इमेज पर इतना
टाइम स्पेंड नहीं करेंगे क्योंकि देखो
लास्ट दो क्लासेस मैंने आपको क्या किया है
की टेक्निक सिखाई है और उसके उसको कैसे
आपको इमेज करना है कैसे जिओ लॉकेट करना है
साड़ी मैं आप लोगों को बता चुका हूं बट
आपको वो साड़ी टेक्निक यहां पर अप्लाई
करनी है
ओके एक और चीज यहां पर आप लोगों के लिए
अनाउंसमेंट आपको मैं कर देता हूं ठीक है
मैं ये क्या कर रहा हूं की ये जो मेरी लैब
है इसको मैं आई बिल ट्राई तू मैक्स ये
पुरी पुरी मैं सॉल्व कर दूंगा अगर मैं
इसमें कुछ छोड़ देता तो आप लोगों को सॉल्व
करने की एडरवाइज मैं इसको ट्राई करूंगा की
पुरी पुरी सॉल्व कर डन कितने में टाइम लगे
बट आप लोग क्या करना है की यहां पर आप
लोगों का एक ही कम है ये जो लैब हम सॉल्व
कर देंगे लेफ्ट सॉल्व करने के बाद आपको
क्या करना है हर एक इमेज पर आपको क्या
करना है एक एनालिसिस परफॉर्म करना है
उसमें आपने क्या देखा उसके बड़े में आप
क्या इनफॉरमेशन एक लेवल तक कलेक्ट कर पे
आपको हर एक टास्क के ऊपर एक
क्वेश्चंस के आंसर
डिटेल रिपोर्ट आपको रेडी करके रखती है
डीटेल्ड रिपोर्ट आपको क्या करके रखती है
रेडी करके रखती है तो वो डिटेल रिपोर्ट
आपको क्या करनी है ड्राइव का लिंक बनाना
है गूगल ड्राइव में और वो हमारे कहां पर
सबमिट पर सेंड कर कमेंट क्षेत्र में सबमिट
करनी है लिंक डेंट के ऊपर तो लिंकडइन का
वेब पेज हमारा वहां पर सबको क्या करना है
उसको सबमिट करना है तो हर चीज आपको दिखाई
दे जो सबसे बेस्ट रिपोर्ट लिखेगा तो उसको
बड़े में भी हम बता दें की सबसे बेस्ट
इसमें बेस्ट एनालिसिस किया है देखते हैं
की किसने कितना शिखा है उसे भी तो प्लीज
आप लोगों से रिक्वेस्ट है अगर कोई
इंटरेस्टेड है किसी को इंटरेस्ट नहीं की
बोला सर हम तो बस लाइव अटेंड करने आते हैं
देखेंगे उसके बाद हम
मुझे कोई फर्क नहीं पड़ेगा बट क्या है कभी
भी कोई इसको रिकॉर्डिंग देख रहा है या
चाहे कोई इसकी आज लाइव देख रहा है अगर कभी
भी क्या कर सकता हूं हमारी चैनल पे जाके
फाइव वाली तू के कमेंट क्षेत्र में क्या
कर सकते हो इसको ड्राइविंग को भेज सकते हो
लिंकडइन पेज के ऊपर
चलते हैं
टास्क क्या है हमारा उसके बाद
इसमें हमें प्रोवाइड किया चलो इसको बैंड
क्लोज कर देते हैं
आपको इमेज एनालिसिस बताया तो इसमें उससे
पहले हम क्या करें क्वेश्चन देख लेते हैं
कौन-कौन से आंसर हमें यहां करने होंगे
पहले बोल रहा है की विच सिटी इसे डी ट्यूब
स्टेशन लोकेटेड इन ओके विच तू स्टेशन
आर डर इन डी स्टेशन
की अंडरग्राउंड कुछ जान के लिए रास्ता
बनाया गया हो सड़क के नीचे से या हो सकता
की इसके अंडरग्राउंड कोई मेट्रो मेट्रो हो
कुछ भी हो सकता है इसके अंडरग्राउंड तो
ऊपर से यहां पर क्या लिखा था जूम करके
देखते हैं यहां पे लिखा है सर्कस
और स्टेशन हां सर के स्टेशन यहां पर देखने
को मिल रहा है बाकी हायड हो गया है और अगर
हम साइड में देखते हैं तो यहां पर गैप
स्टोर करके दिखाई दे रहा है और उसके ऊपर
देखें तो हुंडई का एक लोगो लगा हुआ है
उसके ऊपर थोड़ा सा और देखते हैं तो
कोका-कोला का लोगो लगा इस बिल्डिंग के पास
नेक्स्ट अगर हम देखें जूम करके तो ये हां
एक क्रोम में क्या है एक
साथ में बना हुआ एक बिल्डिंग बनी हुई है
तो यह हमारा एनालिसिस है चलो हम क्या करते
अपना सबसे पहले
तो आप परफॉर्म करना है
की जगह का नाम क्या बता रहा है आपको देख
के
बीकानेरी सर्कस ओके मतलब
[संगीत]
ये तो वही है
बट हो सकता है
[संगीत]
बहुत साड़ी इमेज आपको देखने को मिलेगी
अगर देखें तो देखो
9 इस नोट डन नो नो
स्टेशन
चलो
ओके ओके विकिपीडिया
फोटोस बहुत साड़ी देखने को मिलेंगे क्या
वही है यह
केंद्र
[संगीत]
यार डूइंग समथिंग मिसिंग
चलो चलो
यह पिक्चर्स जो हमारे पास यह
ऐसे पिक्चर हमारे ऐसे सड़क है यह है मतलब
उसके पास है तो अराउंड हम क्या क्या करें
इसका मतलब
कैमरा फुटेज देखोगे तो चीज जगह
कैप स्टोर इधर ही कहानी है तो आपको देखने
को मिल रहा होगा अब वो फोटो देखो हुंडई का
स्टोर था ये गैप स्टोर है बेसिकली अगर हम
बोले तो यही पर होगा
एक सड़क है इधर की कहानी आस-पास है
क्योंकि अभी इसके बिल्कुल एग्जिट पास से
नहीं है तो इस एंगल पर लिया गया होगा
लेकिन लंदन ओके लंदन में है
यह बोल रहा है
हेलो और लंदन इस आईटी राइट
स्टेशन
हमारे पास
[संगीत]
स्टेशन
अरे यार भैया
क्या बोल रहा है
तुम वैसे भी पता कर सकते क्योंकि हमारे
पास इनफॉरमेशन है तो इधर से हम गूगल सर्च
तो हमारे पास कम ही करेगा
चलो टास्क टास्क फोर ए गया इसका इसको हमने
कर दिया नेक्स्ट
अब यह पिक्चर
लिया गया है विच कंट्री इसे दिस बिल्डिंग
लोकेटेड इन और विच सिटी इसे दिस बिल्डिंग
लोकेटेड यह बिल्डिंग का फोटो कहां से लिया
किस बिल्डिंग से लिया गया यह बिल्डिंग
कहां पर इस कंट्री में है और कौन सी सिटी
में है वो वेरी गुड चलो अब यहां पर हम एक
कम करते जनरल एनालिसिस अगर हम करते हैं
क्या दिखाई दे रहा है
और यहां पर यह लगा हुआ है
वी-फी
[संगीत]
वेंकूवर इंटरनेशनल एयरपोर्ट बेंगलुरु
यहां
प्राइवेट इंटरनेशनल एयरपोर्ट
मतलब यह एक एयरपोर्ट की पिक्चर है
जैसे एयरपोर्ट फूड स्टॉक फुटेज
जिसके बड़े में देखो इसके बड़े में वो
जनरल इनफॉरमेशन ये रहा सबको देखने को मिल
रहा होगा ये लाइक डेट इस की तरह
देखा हूं देखो वीडियो इसके ऊपर
जगह ग रही है
एयरपोर्ट के अंदर कोई बिल्डिंग
राइट यस करेक्ट विच कंट्री इसे दिस
बिल्डिंग लोकेटेड इन कौन सी कंट्री तो अब
हमारे पास एयरपोर्ट है
तो हम क्या करते हैं यह देखते हैं कहां पर
है
विकिपीडिया
सिटी ओपन कोर और एयरपोर्ट लोकेशन
मुझे पहले से किसी कम को नहीं पता मैं
आपके सामने ही कर रहा हूं और कॉफी और लोन
या कम कर दिया
तो हम ट्राई करते इसको डाउनलोड करके
इसको बैंड कर देता हूं अभी
इमेज है हमारे पास
और है मतलब
कोई कॉफी शॉप है या कोई
हां कॉफी शॉप आइडिया लगा सकते हैं कोई हो
सकता है
[संगीत]
एडिनबर्ग वूलन मिल ईडन
ईडब्ल्यूएस
मिल्क मुझे यही दिखाई दे रहा है इसमें चलो
एक कम करते हैं फिर इसके बड़े में हम सबसे
पहले
इमेज रिवर्स सर्च कर दें सबसे पहले हमेशा
करते हैं इमेज रिवर्स सर्च क्वेश्चंस
ट्रांसफर बाद में देंगे तो चलो अपलोड कर
देते हैं सबसे पहले कम हमारा यही है की इस
इमेज के बड़े में गूगल को क्या पता है
यह क्या है
इसके बड़े में गूगल
फेसबुक पेज
से हमारे पास
यह है इंस्टाग्राम पेज भी है
स्टडी हमें नहीं चाहिए और यह क्या सबसे
पहले
ईमेल एड्रेस व्हाट इसे डी सरनेम ऑफ डी ओनर
वो इंटरेस्टिंग हेलो
मुझे लगता यही होना चाहिए मोबाइल नंबर
मिल गया और हमें क्या मिले यहां पर ईमेल
आईडी
फाइल आप लोग
किसी भी चीज के ऊपर शक है शंका है तो आपको
वेरीफाई करना ही होगा
वेरीफाई करने बैठेंगे
को तू गूगल मैप
मोबाइल नंबर
[संगीत]
इन दिस कॉपी लोकेटेड का नाम मुझे लगता है
इधर ही था ना
वैसे भी यह कहां गया फेसबुक पेज
नो नो मुझे लगता है
यह वाला
[संगीत]
कॉफी शॉप है
वेबसाइट
आप लोग पढ़ सकते हो
विकिपीडिया ओपन करेंगे
चलो देखते हैं
पूर्वी
चलो मतलब यह भी एक लैब हमने सॉल्व कर दी
काफी है
रिवर्स योर थिंकिंग वो
तो देखते हैं इसमें क्या है
चलो
बैठे हुए हैं
और
काफी मतलब लाइटिंग है
ओपन आईटी
कार्ड
विकिपीडिया
[संगीत]
कार्ड इन देखते हैं क्या पूछना छह रहा हूं
ओके विच रेस्टोरेंट
[संगीत]
कुछ निकनेम देखने को मिल रहा है हमें
क्या सर्च किया है कैट्स दिल्ली लोकेशन और
यही निकाल के ए रहा है
अगर मैं इसको कंफर्म करूंगा
24 होर रेस्टोरेंट तो है
इसके बड़े में
कुछ इन विकिपीडिया
[संगीत]
यह क्या है
प्लेट डिप्टी एडिटर एंड्रयू
प्रो
रिसेंटली
आते डी लीजेंडरी 129 वर्ष ओल्ड
डाउनलोड
[संगीत]
इसको हमें सबसे पहले क्या है
व्हाट इसे डी नाम ऑफ डी स्टैचू
करते हैं
क्लोज करते हैं क्लोज करते हैं क्लोज करते
हैं इसको
लास्ट सेवन
यस बहुत सारे हैं 99
तो देखते हैं न्यूटन ओपन करके और कुछ एक
और है
चला है उसके बाद नेक्स्ट नेक्स्ट
इनफॉरमेशन
नो नोट जस्टिफाई आंसर
[संगीत]
अरे यार तुम बताओ यार
इसका पता नहीं चला की कम भी करता नहीं
करता है
मां मिलर इमेज सिमिलर इमेज
[संगीत]
इस नोट डन फाइंड आउट करने की कोशिश कर रहे
हैं तो हमें क्या करना चाहिए यहां पर कुछ
नहीं है यहां पर कुछ नहीं है
तो हमेशा जाना पड़ेगा
नेक्स्ट रिमाइंडर में
सर्च करने की कोशिश भी करते हैं
यह है कुछ तो है स्टैचू का नाम बट इधर
नहीं ए रहा
है हम
हम
एक आइडिया लेते हैं
एस टी ए टी स्टैचू की स्पेलिंग
स्पेक्ट्रेल पार्क
[संगीत]
इट्स सम लिटिल हार्ट
और जस्टिस पर जो
टास्केट हो गया
यह इसके अंदर का फोटोस नहीं है इसके सामने
मतलब क्या इससे आइडिया लगा सकते हैं की जो
ये आपको फोटो दिखाई दे रही है पिक्चर
दिखाई दे रही है जहां पर यह यह स्टैचू लगा
हुआ है मतलब ये कहानी बिल्डिंग के आउटसाइड
लगा हुआ है उसके सामने कोई बिल्डिंग का
काफी बड़ी बिल्डिंग है क्योंकि जी साइड पे
लागू उसे साइड से देखो 1 2 3 तो हमें
दिखाई दे देंगे 1 2 3 और 3 बिल्डिंग तो
हमने देखा है मतलब ओके चलो एक कम करते फिर
इसको हम
हम रिवर्स करते हैं सबसे पहले हम इसको
करेंगे रिवर्स सर्च करते हैं इसका भी हम
इसका करते हैं रिवर्स सर्च
तो अब ये देखो इसमें कुछ देखने को मिल रहा
है देखने को मिल रहा है
व्हाट इसे डी नाम ऑफ डी कैरेक्टर डेट
स्टैचू एपिक ओके नाम ऑफ डी करैक्टर
इसने कोई इनफॉरमेशन
करते हैं एक आर्टिकल ये ओपन कर लेते हैं
इसके बड़े में कुछ इनफॉरमेशन
[संगीत]
देते हैं
मतलब कोई कोर्ट वाली जगह ऐसी जगह जहां पर
कोई कोर्ट वगैरा है और बिल्कुल से इमेज है
इमेज का नाम क्या है
8000 अकादमी हॉस्पिटल
डिपार्मेंट
[संगीत]
मैसेज किया है
ना इसको
व्हाट इसे डी नाम ऑफ डी करैक्टर
भूल गया क्या
ट्रांसलेट ट्रांसलेट
से से
लोकेशन
ए
व्हाट'एस अबाउट आईटी
नो नो ब्लाइंड जस्टिस
इसी टाइप की अभी लगती है यह भी उसे ओके
फ्रेंड
उसके बड़े में जस्टिस हॉल डी स्केल ऑफ
जस्टिस और स्टेंस अबाउट डी
फ्रंट एंट्रेंस का थे अल्बर्ट बयान नेट
स्टेटस
ओके एक इनफॉरमेशन हमें मिल गई
अलेक्जेंड्रा वर्जीनिया में है ये
ओके ओके
व्हाट वास डी
पावर क्रिश्चियन
हमारा सवाल क्या था ये रहा
स्टैचू लोकेटेड सेल
यम लोकेशन
[संगीत]
और व्हाट अबाउट दिस फोटो
बट स्टैंडर्ड कोई नाम तो होना चाहिए
यह इनफॉरमेशन तो हम एक कम करते हैं प्राइम
जस्टिस
लोकेशन पर चलते हैं गूगल मैप पर गूगल मैप
पर चलते हैं क्या मिलता है
इसके बड़े में कोई इनफॉरमेशन
हमें दिखाई दे रहा ये रहा
ना करते हैं
क्या इसके ऊपर क्या लिखा है
मतलब
तो इसके अपोजिट है हमारे हमने देखा था ना
उस जिला कोर्ट
रिव्यू
[संगीत]
रिलेटेड और कुछ इनफॉरमेशन हमारे पास
जिला कोर्ट में बिल्कुल
लॉकेट
कम करते हैं
मुझे लगता है
बिल्कुल
यह है
वह बिल्डिंग
बिल्कुल एग्जिट
बैक
और बैक
बिल्डिंग
यस बिल्डिंग का नाम हमें मिल गया
बिल्डिंग का नाम हमें मिल गया बिल्डिंग
करते हैं की क्या हो सकता है इसके बड़े
में और इनफॉरमेशन
[संगीत]
स्टेटस
लेडी जस्टिस
इस डी मॉडल
[संगीत]
जे यू एस टी आई सी लेडी जस्टिस
जिला कोर्ट
बट
नाम
क्या है
ना सर
हां स्टेटस का नाम पक्का करना है तो करो
अब हमें क्या हिंट हमारे पास क्या है
आप इसके बड़े में पूरा विकिपीडिया पढ़ना
होगा क्योंकि हो सकता है
पट्टी बंदी हुई है और क्या बिल्कुल हम इस
पर क्या की डेफिनेटली मिक्सर करना पड़ेगा
की इसमें क्या है सच में लेकिन जब भी आप
लेडिस जस्टिस करता हूं लेडी जस्टिस
में क्या सर्च करूं आप लोगों के सामने
मिल गया
नेक्स्ट हम चलते हैं नेक्स्ट
नंबर
में क्या है वो देखते हैं
मतलब मतलब वीडियो थोड़ा सा
वीडियो
मतलब एक चीज ध्यान में रखना जब भी आप क्या
करते हो किसी भी वीडियो के थ्रू क्या करने
की कोशिश करोगे
आप कभी भी किसी भी वीडियो की थ्रू आपको
जिओ लॉकेट करने की कोशिश करोगे तो आप क्या
करो ना सबसे पहले उसको पहले फूल वीडियो को
देखो और उसके बाद क्या की वीडियो क्या
हमेशा क्या है की या तो लेफ्ट तू राइट
टर्न कर रही होगी राइट तो लेफ्ट टर्न कर
रही होगी तो आपको क्या करना है जब वो एक
पुरी देखने पर आपको पता चल जाए की अभी ये
पूरा एंगल कैसे ले रही है लेफ्ट तू राइट
ले रही है रिकॉर्ड करते वक्त या राइट तू
लेफ्ट ले रही है ऐसा कुछ चल रहा था जब
पूरा एक बार वीडियो देखने के बाद उसके बाद
देखो की लेफ्ट तो राइट राइट तू लेफ्ट ये
डिसाइड करने के बाद आप क्या करो मेरी मां
जो जगह है आपको लगता है उनके स्क्रीनशॉट
ले लो स्क्रीनशॉट लेक उनके बाद क्या करूं
एक एक साथ साथ सभी स्क्रीनशॉट को 1 / 1 /
1 दूसरे के ऊपर रख लो मिलने की कोशिश करो
तो इस प्रकार से आपके पास क्या होंगे बहुत
साड़ी इमेज होगी जिसकी वजह से आप क्या
करोगे
कुछ भी कर लो तो शो डेट की आपको क्या है
ये आइडिया मिल जाएगी मुझे एक्चुअल में
करना क्या चाहता हूं अब हम क्या कर रहे
हैं अब देखो फिर से मैं वीडियो देख रहा
हूं
मतलब
कोई हाय मतलब काफी हाइट पर है जो यह
वीडियो शूट कर रहा है और 1 मिनट रुको हां
यह रहा मतलब यह कुछ बालकनी है
आपको ये क्या है
रिवर्स साइड पॉइंट
है इसके ऊपर लिखा हुआ है
नेक्स्ट आपको देखने में मिल रहा है कुछ एक
ऐसी जगह
इंटरेस्टिंग जगह एक है आपके पास ये क्या
है
साइड पॉइंट
[संगीत]
दिखाई दे रहा है सेंट्रल का मतलब क्या है
बेसिकली सेंट्रल होने का नाम राहत है उसके
बाद आपको तीन बड़ी-बड़ी बिल्डिंग दिखाई दे
रही है चलो लास्ट स्टार्ट और एनसीसी हम
क्या करते हैं अभी चलते हैं और हम क्या
करते हैं
मारते कहां पर है सेंट्रल सिंगापुर
का मतलब क्या सिंगापुर में हो सकता है
क्या
सीधा ओपन कर देते हैं इसके अंदर अपने गूगल
मैप के अंदर क्या लगता है इसके पास इमेज
तो होगी होगी
ओके इनसाइड आउट इनसाइड से मुझे मतलब नहीं
है
ओके मुझे 360 व्यू मिल गया मुझे 360 व्यू
मिल गया
रिवर भी है अगर मैं इस वीडियो
लिखा हुआ है एक तो इस बिल्डिंग के ऊपर
उसमें और इसके अपोजिट भी है
बिल्कुल देखो उसके सामने से वीडियो शूट हो
रहा है चलो हम एक कम करते हैं वीडियो शूट
हो रहा है एक मिनट जूम करने से पहले ये
रहा वीडियो शूट हो रहा है ऐसे
एक मिनट एक मिनट वीडियो शूट बिल्कुल सामने
से तो हम क्या करते हैं
[संगीत]
अगर देखो ये रहा ये क्योंकि एंगल अगर
देखोगे थोड़ा सा बैक करता हूं मैं अगर अगर
आपको देखेगा देखने को मिलेगा 1 मिनट 1
मिनट 1 मिनट 1 मिनट 1 मिनट ये रहा जूम
करने के बाद अगर आपको देखोगे बिल्कुल मेरे
सामने है और उसके बाद एक एंगल
पर है और नई सिंगल पे हूं तो हमें कम से
अमेजिंग कर सकते हैं की यह कुछ यह वाली
बिल्डिंग हो शक्ति इनमें से या तो यह हो
शक्ति है
उसके बाद हम देखते हैं और कुछ दिखे रहा है
मेरे को
देख नहीं का रहा हूं मतलब ये मुझे इतना
आइडिया मिल गया सेंट्रल ये चलो
और और ये वाली देखो ये वही अगर आपको नहीं
देख का रहे हो तो हमें एक कम करते हैं बैक
करते हैं इसको चलो हमारे पास मिल गया
कहां गए
अरे बैक करो
और उसके बाद चलो चलो
बिल्डिंग
है जिसकी मैं बात कर रहा हूं ये वाली
बिल्डिंग हो शक्ति है ये वो बिल्डिंग हो
शक्ति है अगर मैं इसको और टर्न करता हूं
एंगल बनाता हूं मैं अगर एंगल से देखने को
अगर मैं ये रहा ये होटल के अंदर और मैं
थोड़ा सा
3d में राहत हूं और इसको अगर मैं देखूंगा
तीन बिल्डिंग
यह रही यह तीन बिल्डिंग है सामने बिल्कुल
दिखाई दे रही थी उसके होटल के सामने जिनके
ऊपर क्या पार्क है वो भी दिखाई थी मतलब
मैं कंफर्म हो गया जो मेरा जो वीडियो ली
हुई होगी कंफर्म होगी वो कहां चली गई होगी
डेफिनेटली इस बिल्डिंग से ली गई होगी अगर
मैं एक कम करता हूं इधर कुछ है 360 तो मैं
देखा हूं एक मिनट मैं 1 मिनट हम टर्न करते
हैं
अब यह बिल्डिंग है मेरे लिए डाउट करने के
लिए ये क्या है यह है
मेरी नव होटल है
कम कर सकते हैं
और हम हम एक कम करते हैं इसको देखते हैं
वैसे ही फोटो है
अंदर का फोटो
सबमिट करते हैं इसको हम क्या करते हैं ना
होटल या यही नाम हो सकता है व्हाट इसे डी
नाम ऑफ होटल मी फ्रेंड्स को तो मैं कम
करता हूं इसका नाम लिखना हूं मैं अगर मैं
इसको
चाहिए
एंगल जो उसमें देखो हां राइट क्योंकि वो
जितने भी एंगल से सारे इधर से बन रहे हैं
और यही वो होटल है अगर यहां हम एक कम अगर
देख लीजिए अगर चाहे तो ये रहे अब यहां पर
क्या है
इतना ही फोटो ले गया जो बहुत पहले के आई
[संगीत]
वैसे भी आउटसाइड का व्यू है ही नहीं कहानी
पर कहानी पर भी आउटसाइड का व्यू नहीं है
इसके अंदर
इसको हम क्या करें
एक बार फिर से हम देखते हैं ट्रांसफार्मर
को ओपन करते हैं
लास्ट नंबर सेवन ये रहा अब इससे एक बार
फिर से हम एक बार सर्च करते हैं
जल्दी में कुछ हमने मिस किया होगा लास्ट
नंबर 7
नंबर 7 ओपन और नेक्स्ट नेक्स्ट
तो हमें कम करें
फेसबुक है
क्रोम मास्टर सिलेंडर क्या यही तो नहीं हो
सकता
है
वो अभी हमें कुछ मिला है
मोटरसाइकिल 2012
दिसंबर
प्रॉब्लम
अप डीसी में
तो लोकेशन
हमें कम करते हैं
हम पीछे कुछ और ढूंढने कुछ करते हमें कुछ
ना कुछ तो मिलेगा
[संगीत]
यह नहीं है
यह नहीं
है
और इसका नाम क्या है
और
ओके
ट्विटर हैंडल इनका
हमें अपना जो क्वेश्चंस ट्रांसफर हमें मिल
गया
एक बार मुझे बताइए
सबको मजा आया नहीं आया
रिपोर्ट लिखना है कितने डिटेल रिपोर्ट लिख
सकता है अपनी सर्चिंग के बड़े में
बताइए बताइए